Kung Fu Panda to a movie that I had
absolutely no idea what to expect up I
enjoyed the first one a lot I was very
surprised by it was very funny but more
the biggest surprises I got out of the
first one was that the Kung Fu action
was actually really exhilarating really
well done stuff and just great animation
that was back when everything wasn't 3d
see for a number of reasons I just
thought this might not be good and I was
worried because reason number one Jack
Black's films as of late aren't exactly
inspiring reason number two it's a
sequel reason number three the trailer
was fun but met in this film the Panda
named PO gets to explore a lot of his
past who is real parents were where his
parents came from because obviously his
goofs father probably isn't in his
bloodline evil emperor Shen which is
this peacock has this new weapon he's
destroying towns and stuff and kung-fu
warriors are getting destroyed by
because they can't block a missile with
their fists and so him and his buddies
set out on a journey to destroy them I
like country panda - it was fun once
again great kung fu action lots of fun
action really good image is a good
villain - Emperor Shen he was a good
bill the voice acting is just all-around
great for this film the 3d is good
please keep in mind as I say that I
don't like 3d I don't want 3d anymore
you know I'm just the fact even I'm
saying it's good because it's good for
what 3d has to offer it's easy to do 3d
with animation films because they can
perfect everything in the computer
everyone knows I'm sick of 3d even if
the 3d is done well the image is almost
always darkened by the glasses and when
you walk out of the theater my eyes are
always stinging our eyes are not created
to look into an image like that and so
afterwards they're always kind of
hey-hey but for 3d standards it's done
well the things I did not like about
this film I did not think it was nearly
as funny as the first at all I thought a
lot of the humor fell flat at times
there was definitely funny parts don't
get me wrong even though I enjoyed this
film more than I think I think kids
would actually because I was able to
understand a lot more of the story than
the average you know little child I
think it's actually a little bit too
deep for kids believe it or not there's
gonna be a lot of kids you know maybe
five and under who aren't going to fully
grasp for the story because it really
gets involved with his real parents a
backstory and everything and I think a
lot of kids just gonna be like action
you know he got hit in the balls or
whatever he not I mean but it was well
done I enjoyed the film you're not going
to be bored with this film the animation
looks great a kung fu is awesome the
characters are well done there's some
really nice opening in this film that I
really liked that remind me a lot of
Samurai Jack there's a really nice
animation that's 2d style regular
cartoons which is nice because you know
that reminds me my childhood when
everything was in 2d also the score is
very good in the whole film like I bet
you the scores by Hans Zimmer cuz he
does everything now oh my gosh it is by
Hans Zimmer and seriously I'm never
joined with John Powell who did the
Bourne
you know the Bourne Identity scores and
I liked him a lot too there's a lot of
good things in this movie at times it is
noticeable that it's a children's you
know film a kid's film that's really the
only fault I have with it some of the
comedy falls flat I'm going to give it
three out of four stars
I don't like it as much as the first one
but it's definitely a fun movie your
kids will enjoy it you're probably out
fun with it too